who will uh talk to us about knowledge
compilation and
boolean functional synthesis so and it's
kind of a
semi follow-up maybe or at least
somewhat related to what we heard
uh last week uh um
so proticus has done a lot of work on on
counting and sampling
uh formal methods automata
logic you know you name it so but we
usually don't spend too much time
dwelling on
our our speakers and their series we
just let them get down to it and give
their amazing talk so
practic without further ado please
uh thanks jacob uh yeah so
last week uh some of you uh may
have attended a talk where i talked
about
uh some algorithms which is uh
particularly the guess check and repair
paradigm for boolean functional
synthesis
so this talk is not going to go into
that at all so i'm going to talk about
knowledge compilation
but of course you know there is a bit of
overlap
in terms of the introduction and the
related work and so on so
my apologies uh for you know that little
bit of overlap
but hopefully we will we will soon go
beyond that
and uh and talk about knowledge
compilation
okay so uh this is a joint work
with uh my colleagues akshay krishna
and shethel and our students
and let's
get to some motivation right away
and you know boolean functions are
you know often easy to specify
relationally rather than as
directly as a function in terms of the
inputs so
here is a simple example and i also want
to talk about another example
uh you know in today's talk so so this
example
talks about an arbiter where there are
two boolean valued requests and two
boolean
valued grants and let's say this is a
very simplified arbiter so we are
talking about
you know the grants just depending on
the requests at that particular point of
time
at the same instant of time so
one could think of specifying the
behavior of this arbiter by saying that
if there is an input then
if there's an input request then at
least one of the output requests should
go high
there are writers shouldn't be uh
denying to both the requesters if at
least one of them has requested
uh and of course uh this are this arbit
our arbitration is happening for a
shared resource so both of them should
not be granted at the same
time and if uh you know grant one has
been set high then there must have been
a request
on uh request requester one must have
requested something
and if grant two has been set either
high then requested two must have
requested something and of course you
know one could uh develop this further
and in fact one could even talk about
uh an arbiter where the properties are
stated with respect to some temporal
specifications
uh but you know just to keep things
simple for this
uh motivating uh example
we're just talking about a combinational
view of the arbiter
okay so if you look at the specification
uh we
we don't know what g1 and g2 are as
functions of r1 and r2
uh and but you know if we have to
design the arbiter we need to obtain g1
and g2 as functions of r1 and r2
and in this particular case you know
there are more than one solutions for
example two of the solutions are shown
here
and you know any one of these
if you pick if you choose g1 to be r1
and negation r2 and g2 to be r2
and the other solution being symmetric
uh if you choose any one of these
solutions
then if you plug it in you will see that
it satisfies the specification
so the question is that starting
from the given relation between inputs
and outputs
how do i obtain the outputs as
functions of the inputs and
this is uh the boolean functional
synthesis problem
we are trying to synthesize boolean
functions from a relational
specification
uh the specification is propositional
it is uh it doesn't have any temporal
operators in it
and therefore the functions that we are
trying to synthesize are also going to
be propositional functions
or combinational circuits which
when plugged into the specification
should satisfy the specification
okay so uh the formal definition is
as follows so we are given a boolean
relation
uh which is uh you know the formula
phi uh the input variables are denoted
in
blue that's the notation i will be
following throughout
the output variables are in red and a
vector of input variables and a vector
of output variables
are represented by these capital x and
capital y
and what we want to do is given
this uh specification phi in terms of
the inputs
and the outputs we want to synthesize
functions f1 to fm
one for each of the outputs such
that for every value of x
if there is some way to satisfy the
specification which means that there
exists some values of y1 through ym
which will cause phi to evaluate to true
for that value of x
then f1x still fmx will also satisfy the
specification
when plugged in place of y1 through yn
okay so uh what this is saying
is that
i can effectively obtain witnesses for
these
existentially quantified variables by
using these functions over here
and whenever there exists a value for
these existentially quantified variables
that makes the formula that makes the
specification true
then the functions also serve that
purpose and in the literature
these functions f j x
are also called s column functions for
the output variables
in terms of the inputs so we're going to
use the same notation
uh in this talk as well
now there are a couple of things to note
here uh
the first is that if the number of
inputs is small
you know then this is not a very
interesting problem because i could just
you know enumerate all the two rays to
cardinality of
x valuations of the inputs and for each
one of them i could make a sat call
find out the values of y and just
and just tabulate them so this problem
is interesting when the number of inputs
is
large interestingly this problem also
stays interesting
when the specification is quote unquote
unrealizable
as in the classical definition of
realizability so the classical
definition
of realizability we say that a
specification phi
is realizable uh if for every value of
the inputs
i can find some value for the outputs uh
which
makes the specification true but you
know what we will see very shortly is
that there are
indeed several cases uh several
interesting uh specifications
where it is not the case that for every
value of the input i can find an
output that makes the specification true
but there are indeed interesting
interesting cases of the inputs x uh for
which there exists y
and it is for those x's that i
do really care about finding the right
values of y
so uh even if the specification is
unrealizable in the classical sense uh
this problem
is interesting as long as there are some
x's for which
uh you know i can find wise such that
the specification is
true and for those x's my scolum
function should give the right values
for y
uh and for the other x's for which there
are no y's
such that the specification can be made
true the value of this column functions
are completely inconsequential
specification can you give an example
oh yeah i'm just coming to the next
slide yeah let's see in the next slide
so so here is a very interesting example
of an unrealizable specification uh
which relates to bounded integer
factorization
so suppose i have two n-bit integers
uh call them y one and y two and i have
a two n-bit integer call it
x and my relational specification says
that uh x is the product the
n-bit unsigned product of y1 and y2
and y1 is not equal to the n-bit
unsigned integer 1 and y2 is not equal
to the n-bit unsight integer 1.
so if you view this as a formula this is
just relating x y 1 and y 2
and of course if y 1 and y 2 were
inputs and x was an output you know
there would be an easy way to synthesize
this just
you know let's build a multiplier
circuit but the interesting case happens
when we treat x as an input and y one
and y was an output
because in that case we are really
asking for non-trivial factors
of x of the integer represented by x
and this is an example of a non-real
of a unrealizable specification in the
classical sense
because if you feed a value of x which
is
which denotes a prime number then there
are no values for y 1 and y 2 which are
going to satisfy the specification
because you know the only factors of a
prime number are itself and 1
and we have disallowed either of the
factors from being 1
right so so this specification can be
satisfied
if you treat x as an input and y one and
y two as outputs
this specification can be satisfied only
for non prime
x uh for prime for x which represents a
prime number
there are no why one invited which
satisfies this and uh
of course you know i i don't need to
emphasize to this audience that
uh this is a very important problem this
is the factorization problem
in fact uh you know the uh
you know the hardness of cryptographic
uh
you know protocols that we have uh
a lot of them depend on the hardness of
uh
not being able to factorize the product
of two primes
right so if i give such a product uh
there is there are just you know
two primes that will serve as the values
for y one and y two but if i
could solve this problem uh efficiently
then i would be able to crack those
crypto systems so so this is a
a hard problem so it also tells us that
it's not going to be easy to solve this
problem
and we are really asking for every
non-prime x find non-trivial factors
and for prime x of course we don't care
now uh there is uh you know uh i mean
since this question came up
about uh you know what are other uh
unrealizable specifications
so there is uh yet another you know very
very important class of unrealizable
specifications that we deal with
is when we are doing uh let us say
temporal synthesis and we
uh you know construct a winning region
and we try to ensure
that uh whenever we are in a state we
take a transition into the winning
region now it could indeed be the case
that from certain states
there are no transitions to the winning
regions uh so once again the
specification is unrealizable in that
sense
but uh indeed you know we want to make
sure that a controller that synthesized
is such that from every state if there
is a way to come into the winning region
we do uh you know apply those inputs
that get us into the winning region
so actually there are uh you know board
games are another example where from
every position you may not have a
winning move but you do want to come up
with a function
such that for all positions from which
you have a winning move
you do want to take the winning move so
so there are actually a lot of
classically unrealizable specifications
but for which it still makes a lot of
sense
to find out these scoring functions
okay uh so so did that answer your
question
uh yes yes okay thank you
uh okay so
and uh you know there are as i said lots
of applications of this problem
so crypt analysis it is interesting but
you know this we know is going to be
hard
there is you know an application where
you're given a symbolic state transition
relation
and you want to disjunctively decompose
it which means that
the union of the transitions in the
various components
are the set of transitions in the
original uh
you know state transition diagram and so
this disjunctive decomposition can also
be reduced to boolean functional
synthesis
uh and of course quantifier elimination
this comes from the definition of
boolean functional synthesis that we
want to get
f such that when i plug in f for y i
achieve the result of quantifying out y
from uh phi
uh certifying qbf sat solvers uh
you know as i said we are really getting
a witness a certificate for
why when we are saying that this
function evaluates to true
this specification evaluates to true uh
and there's a nice survey of
applications of certificates of qbf send
solvers
that was published in a recent paper
reactive controller synthesis i already
described this briefly
we want to synthesize moves to stay
within the winning region
program synthesis also you know
combinatorial sketching
and complete functional synthesis uh
both of which can be thought of
can be reduced to uh you know findings
column functions that satisfy a
specification like this
uh and of course uh you know in program
synthesis and
complete functional synthesis one may be
interested
in going beyond uh booleans
for you know big vectors we can still
sort of blast them and
reason about them in booleans but this
problem is interesting even when you're
talking about integers or real
accelerationals
then there are also applications in
repair and partial synthesis of circuits
where once again it amounts to solving
this quantified formula by finding a
certificate of the existentially
quantified variables
so uh so there are a bunch of
applications and this is uh you know
some sampling of those and of course uh
since there are applications
people have also tried to solve this
problem and you know there's a very rich
literature on solving this problem
interestingly uh
you know more than a century back uh
george bull and uh you know close to the
beginning of the last century lowenham
looked at a problem which is called
finding the most general unifiers for
propositional formulas and there is a
close connection between finding most
general unifiers
and boolean functional synthesis and
uh you know much later the algorithms
that
you know boole and lowenham the the
methods that they had proposed for
finding most general unifiers
which can be used to find scrolling
functions
were also tried out implemented but
unfortunately they turn out to be
very inefficient in practice you know
interestingly uh scolam came much later
than i mean the scrolling functions were
introduced in the 1920s
uh but much before that uh you know
people were already studying problems
which had
close connections with uh scrolling
function synthesis
uh there's also this very nice
uh you know uh
sequence of papers which talks about
that well if the formula i mean if i'm
indeed talking about
realizable specifications then the
formula for all x
exists y phi of x y uh is valid
and therefore there should be a proof of
validity of this and
it should be possible to extract from
that proof of validity
the the witness y for every value for
for every value of x and indeed
uh this has been used uh you know quite
successfully
interestingly this can be used only for
realizable specifications
which is of course a very important
class of specifications but
when we want to talk about things like
uh integer factorization
the specification is not realizable so
you know this formula is not valid so we
can't use this technique
there has been work where uh you know
templates have been used
templates for this column functions and
then you can suitably instantiate the
templates and
uh sort of check whether they're
satisfying the formula
uh there's uh you know a very classical
line of work
uh which involves self-substitution and
function composition and i'm going to
talk about these a little bit
as we go deeper in the talk uh but the
primary focus of today's stock
is going to be synthesis from a special
normal form representations of the
specification
and uh i'm going to talk briefly about
work done
uh by several other groups
about synthesizing scrolling functions
from robd's
representations of the specification and
then i'll talk about
uh how we have been able to generalize
that
uh to something called a synthesis
negation normal form so this will be the
primary focus of today's talk
but of course yeah is it important at
this point that we can parse
robe dd or sin nnf or you'll take
you know should we feel intimidated or
you'll tell us later
uh i will be telling yeah i will be
talking about both
robb ddds and synonyms later i just
wanted to highlight this as
uh one of the existing approaches okay
great thanks
uh yeah so i i will be talking about
these uh later
in you know much more detail
uh then there is a very interesting line
of work
uh you know by marcus rabe and sanji
sesha
where they basically take uh
the essence of how cdcl solving works uh
and they convert it to a technique
which they call incremental
determinization which can be used
to uh find out school and functions from
a specification given as a cnf formula
there have also been quantifier
instantiation techniques and smt solvers
recently
particularly in the scigus competition
you know these
kinds of solvers have been very
successful
and those can also be used to solve
boolean functional synthesis
we have done some work earlier on what
is called input output component
separation
i'm not going to be talking about this
further and
in the talk last week i really had
elaborated a little bit more
on the uh guest check repair paradigm
which also has turned out to be
a very successful paradigm for solving
this
this problem but today's talk uh will be
primarily focused
around uh synthesis from special normal
form
representations of this specification
okay uh so
you know so we are going to ask that
uh you know what kind of representations
of the specification
can perhaps make this column function
problem
easy and in order to do this we have to
sort of
uh decide on how are we going to
represent the specifications
so that we can then talk about special
forms of those representations
so throughout this talk i'm going to be
using boolean circuits which are
basically directed acyclic graphs
with conjunction disjunction and
negation labeled internal nodes
and variable labeled leaves to represent
both the specification and the scolam
function so
our specification is going to be a
circuit
which has uh the inputs x
x i's and the outputs y j's and
the output of the circuit is the
prepositional formula
phi of x y which represents the
specification
now why do we choose uh these general
boolean circuits to represent
specifications
uh because you know if you give me other
forms of specifications let us say
uh binary decision diagrams or
conjunctive normal form formulas or
disjunctive normal form formulas
or you know other other forms
in which you want to give the
specification it can be very easily
converted to these boolean circuits
and so we sort of took this boolean
circuit as a general uh
general enough form for representing the
specification
and what i want to do is at the end of
boolean function synthesis
i also want to get another boolean
circuit but this time
this circuit is going to have only the
x's as inputs
and it is going to have once column
function
for each output variable y okay
so this is also going to be a circuit
and this will be a multi-output circuit
so each of these functions fi's will
depend only on the x's
and as you can see in this figure it is
perfectly possible that sub-circuits can
be shared
for example the output of this or node
here feeds into this
and node which finally drives this f1
x and the output of this r node also
drives f k
x so it's perfectly possible for
sub circuits to be shared over here this
is a general
boolean circuit that we're talking about
multi input multi output
so the important point is that uh
we are not saying that we want this
column functions
as an robdddd which would be a special
which would you know
translate to some special kind of
circuits or we are not saying that we
want the output to be a cnf or a dnf
we're just saying can we get just a
boolean circuit as the output
now once i say that i'm going to sort of
you know do my reasoning by assuming the
input specification is given as a
circuit and the output specifications
given as a circuit
is the output scoring functions are
obtained as circuits
you will agree that any complexity
theoretic lower bounds that i can obtain
for this problem
but the inputs are given as circuits and
the outputs are obtained as general
circuits
any complexity theoretic lower bounds
will also apply
when i put more restrictions on like i
want the outputs as robd's or i want the
inputs to be represented as cnf and so
on
right because uh any lower bounds that i
obtain going from a circuit
representation of the specification to a
circuit representation of the scrolling
function
uh you know as long as those uh lower
bounds are more than polynomial
uh will also apply if let's say i want
to go from robd specifications to robd
scolling functions
or cnf specifications to rbdt scoring
functions and so on right because
there are easy translations from uh
each of these forms to uh
you know to the input specification as a
circuit and a lower bound that i get for
a general circuit
must also hold for a for a very special
form of a circuit if i want that
so so this representation kind of serves
as a nice
uh you know starting point for asking
uh how hard is this problem going to be
in general
what are the lower bounds and uh it is
not surprising that this problem isn't
be hard this is
fairly easy to see you can take a sat
problem and just
you know existentially quantify out all
the variables and say that well these
are all my outputs i have no inputs
so the outputs now have to be generated
as constants by its column functions
and of course this will solve the
c n f sat problem so it's of course np
hard
the interesting question that we want to
ask is that
uh okay now that we know it is np hard
so we are not going to get a very time
efficient algorithm
but even if i was willing to spend
exponential time
uh is it possible to synthesize compact
scrolling functions
right so i can i make the can i ensure
okay i think there's an echo from
somewhere so so can i ensure
that i'm going to get uh small scrolling
functions at the outputs
uh and i'm willing to spend as much time
as is needed for that
so we we basically asked that
can we always do this can we always
generate compact scrolling functions
and typically when we are talking about
these lower bound results for circuit
size
uh you know typically we refer to
monotone circuits and
of course these seminal results from
raspberry and alon and gopana
however this talking about monotone
circuits is probably not the right thing
in our context because a monotone
circuit has this property that
if you change an input from 0 to one the
output cannot change from
one to zero and there is no reason to
believe that solemn function should be
monotone
right so uh if scoring functions are not
monotone
then you know i can't really apply these
uh circuit lower bounds for monotone
circuits
and uh one might therefore ask that well
uh you know since the circuit lower
bounds for monotone circuits are not
going to apply
uh is it possible i mean since we have
this full generality of
uh you know we can put and or not gates
wherever we want in our schooling
functions
uh is there a reason for hope can we
always get uh small scolam functions as
circuits
unfortunately uh you know a couple of
years back we were able to show that uh
unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses to the second level
uh there exists uh specifications
for which the scolling function sizes
must be super polynomial in the size of
the specification
and uh you know a slight extension of
that argument shows that
uh unless the non-uniform exponential
time hypothesis
fails uh of course this is i mean
there's a very strong hypothesis the
non-uniform exponential time hypothesis
but unless that fails i mean this is
it's still open whether it is it stands
or it fails
but unless it fails uh then there exists
specifications
for which column function sizes must be
exponential in the size of
the specification and
the basic argument behind these is is
not very hard
it's really saying that you can use this
column functions to sort of
uh do lots of interesting things once
you formulate the problem appropriately
so well uh given this bad news uh
we know that you know scrolling function
synthesis booleans column function
synthesis
uh is not going to be time efficient or
space efficient in general
and so we cannot hope for uh efficient
algorithms
uh that will work in general okay
but of course uh you know that doesn't
mean uh we should
uh you know give up solving this problem
this is an important problem
and uh you know
the basic investigated this problem a
little bit further and we found
that if we could represent the
specification in some special normal
form
then indeed we can show that the boolean
functional synthesis problem
can be solved uh in polynomial time in
space
and this was interesting and
this basically led us to you know the
main subject of today's talk which is
the synthesis negation normal form and
as i'll show you that this subsumes
well-known forms like
uh reduced ordered binary decision
diagrams even functional decision
diagrams
uh decomposable negation normal forms
uh adnan talked about it
in a very beautiful talk uh and you know
a couple of
weeks back or maybe this was last week
and we will show that uh you know the
sin nnf
subsumes these things of course there is
a caveat here
that given the conditional lower bounds
we have
this does mean that uh compiling a given
specification to synonymous cannot be
efficient in general
because once it is incident after that
synthesis is polynomial time and space
and we have some lower bounds saying
that synthesis is not going to be easy
uh there it's probably going to be super
polynomial uh
you know time and space so this means
that there will be
hurdles in general in compiling a given
specification to
an arbitrary specification to uh the
synthesis negation normal form
but the silver lining is that our
experimental evidence seems to show
that uh sin nnf and
something called refined synonyms which
i will be talking about more detail
uh is actually not very uncommon in
practice i mean we found
a large percentage of our benchmarks
that we have been looking at
uh to have uh you know these refined
synonym form
or to be easily reducible to a refined
synonym form
uh in addition uh because uh you know as
i mentioned here and as i will explain
later that synonyms since it subsumes
reduced ordered binary decision diagrams
and decomposable negation normal form
so if i could compile my specification
to reduce ordered binary decision
diagram
using any variable order to a functional
decision diagram or a decomposible
negation normal form
i already have a c n n f and after that
synthesis is easy
and of course uh you know robdddds dnafs
these
have been studied for a long time and
there are very mature compilation tools
that exist
so we could also use these to sort of
get to cinnamon f
and from there do efficient synthesis
okay but as i said
because cinelnf subsumes all of these uh
we actually don't require the full
capabilities of the strong normal forms
and i'm going to
discuss this in more detail uh however
we can use
existing tools that uh that are used for
such compilation
to compile to synonyms to sort of
restricted forms of synonyms okay
so uh so let's see uh you know what lies
at the core
of this boolean functional synthesis
problem and
to begin with i i will start off with by
saying that suppose i have just one
output
so the cardinality of the vector of
outputs y is one
and i now have to find a single function
f x
such that uh for every x
uh whenever there exists a boolean value
for this
single output variable which satisfies
the specification
phi if i used f of x in place
uh of y the specification will also be
satisfied so this is the single output
case
and uh we can actually understand what's
going on in the single output case very
clearly
so this part is uh you know this slide
in the next are
uh what i had also shown in the talk
last week as part of the tfcs seminar
uh but i think let's go through it so
that it sets the tone for what's coming
next
so uh here uh i have represented
the set of all valuations of x represent
remember that x is a finite vector of
boolean variables
so of course i can conceptually think of
the set of all possible valuations of x
there are only finitely many of them
and then suppose i ask that what
what is the subset of these valuations
of x uh
for which i cannot set y to 1 if i were
to satisfy
5 right so i'm asking which are those
x's
such that you know if x takes on those
values
then uh it would not make sense to set
y to 1 if you were to satisfy the
specification
and this is obtained very simply by
taking the specification
phi of x y setting y to 1 and then just
negating it
right so this gives you all the
valuations of x
such that you know if x took one of
those values and if you set
y to 1 then of course 5 will evaluate to
false
right so here is a simple example uh
suppose phi
was this cn formula and
i want to find out what are the values
of x uh
x1 and x2 for which uh it doesn't make
sense to set
y21 so all i'm going to do is i'm going
to set y21
in this formula so i'm going to get x1
r1 here x1 and x2 are 0 here
and then i'm going to negate the
conjunction of these two clauses
and that gives me negation x1 and
negation x2 and you can indeed see that
if both
x1 and x2 are false then uh this form
the specification phi
simplifies to y and negation y
and there is uh you know it doesn't make
sense to set white one
uh in that case if both x1 and x2 are
set to false you cannot make the
specification true in that case okay
now i could ask a similar question that
what are the values of
x's for which it doesn't make sense to
set y to 0
and the answer is very similar so just
take
uh phi of x y set y to 0 and negate
the function that you get and similarly
for this example
i set y to 0 here and negation y to 1
here
and then when i simplify it i get
negation x 1
and once again if you see that if you
set x 1 to false
then this specification simplifies to
y conjunction something and since it is
y conjunction something
it doesn't make sense to set y to 0 if
you want to satisfy the specification
for those values of x
okay so this is uh all good and simple
and we could superimpose these two sets
which i call gamma x and delta x
gamma x are those values where you can't
set y to 1
delta x at those values where you can't
set y to 0 and indeed there could be
some overlap
it just means that when x takes on any
of these yellow values
then you i mean there's no way to make
the specification true
regardless of whether you set y to true
or false specification will evaluate to
false
and these white uh or
non-colored circles these represent the
cases where
you can set x to true or x to false and
the specification will
be satisfied in both cases right so
in the clo cases you can set uh y to
whatever
and the specification won't be satisfied
in the white cases you can set y to
whatever and the specification will be
satisfied in these
uh red cases you must set
y to zero it doesn't make sense to set y
to one
and in these uh green cases you must set
white 1
it doesn't make sense to set y to 0.
okay
and it's not very hard to show from here
that every scrolling function for the
single output y
must be an interpolant between this
green region
and the red region okay so if i call
that delta minus gamma
and gamma minus delta so must be an
interpolant between
delta minus gamma and gamma minus delta
which means that it must evaluate to
true
uh in this green part and it must not
evaluate to true in this red part
at every other place it's fine you know
you can include as many of the yellow
dots or white dots
it doesn't make any difference and this
is nice
because you know we are able to sort of
synthesize why very nicely
and you know we can look at specific
interpolants
which are actually very easy to compute
so for example
uh you know this part shaded here it's
just saying
negation of the part where you should
not set it to one
right so gamma was the part where you
shouldn't set y to one so you take the
negation of this whole thing
that's already an interpolant or you can
take
delta where you shouldn't set it to 0
and therefore you set it to 1
and this is also going to be an
interpolant and it's not hard to see
that
both of these are actually interpolants
between delta minus gamma and gamma
minus delta
so uh you know these two interpolants
are just obtained
by taking the original specification
plugging in one
for uh the output variable and
using that as this column function and
this is take the specification plug-in 0
for the output variable
negate the specification that you get
after that
and that will serve as the scolan
function
so we are going to uh primarily focus on
this specific case which is just
obtained by setting one
uh to the output variable if there is a
single output variable
uh but you know one could also do
whatever reasoning we are
saying by taking negation phi of x0
that's also fine
so just for convenience i'm going to go
ahead with 5x1
okay so this was fine but uh now you
know i mean if there was just one output
perhaps it was
not a very interesting problem so what
happens if i have
multiple outputs okay and so here is a
simple example where i have two outputs
y1 and y2 and two inputs x1 and x2
and the first thing that you note is
that because i have
y1 xor 2 as a you know conjuncted as a
clause that is conjuncted here
therefore whatever scrolling functions i
get for y 1 and y 2
if they have to make the specification
phi
true they must be the logical negations
of each other
and this is kind of our first stumbling
block where we realize that when we have
more than one output
we cannot synthesize these outputs
independently
they are intertwined in general okay
so uh this is bad news because we had
found a very nice way of solving the
case for one output
so we asked that well can we do
something to reduce this to a synthesis
problem on one output
and the kind and the answer is yes kind
of yes and
what we want to do is we want to say
that
you know informally we want to say that
okay let us synthesize
f2x such that if i use that f2x
i can always find some value of y1 later
on which will satisfy the specification
right so remember there are these two
outputs y one and y two
and i realize that uh you know i can't
synthesize them independently
so i'm saying that okay uh let's just
ignore the output y1 for the time being
and uh let's synthesize f2x but while
synthesizing it
we should somehow ensure that whatever
function i synthesize
if i plug that in for y2 i can later on
find
a value for y1 for each x i can find a
value for y1
such that this formula is true so
informally we want to do this
and if i were to formalize this i'm
basically saying
that let's look at this formula exists
y1
phi of x y 1 y 2 as the new spec so i
call this
phi 1 of x y 2 right so
uh this is kind of like a you know dirty
trick that we are doing by saying that
well
we don't know how to deal with multiple
outputs in a nice way
so let's pretend that we just want to
deal with one output
and let us make sure that the
specification from which i am going to
synthesize this one output
is not the original specification but it
is derived from the original original
specification in such a way
that if i plug in whatever f2 i
synthesize for y2
then i can subsequently find the y1
which
i can plug in for y1 in the original
specification
and make the specification true okay
so so this sounds like uh a hack
uh you know one way to proceed forward
and let's see what it what happens in
our case
so in our case uh which is
uh this example x 1 or x 2 or y 1
conjuncted with y 1 x or y 2
if if you existentially quantify out y 1
from here
you get this formula x1 or x2 or
negation y2
and you know now this is a specification
with a single output
and i can now go ahead and just set that
output to 1
and i get this as my scolum function for
y2
and because i had synthesized this
column function
not from the original specification but
from this new specification
which was derived from the original
specification by existentially
quantifying out y1
therefore i know that whenever i plug in
this f2
i will have a way of getting y1
in terms of x and so that's exactly what
we're going to do
once we have f2 we're going to plug in
f2 over here and that will give us
a specification which just has y one and
x in it so once again it's a single
output specification
and i can again uh do the same trick so
in this particular case
uh by plugging in f2 x as x one or x two
in the specification
i get this as my new modified
specification x1 or x2
xor y1 and then i can just plug in 1
for the only loan output variable that's
present here
and that gives me negation x1 x2 and
let's just cross
check with this all of this made sense
so if
so i'm saying that if y 1 is negation x
1
or x 2 and y 2 is x 1 or x 2 then of
course they are negations of each other
and so this y 1 x or y 2 plus will
evaluate to true
and here you see x 1 or x 2 or y 1 and y
1 was negation x 1 and x 2
so therefore this also evaluates to true
and this works for
all x's for all values of x 1 and x 2.
so this work for this
uh little example over here now if we
were to generalize this
and we had to go beyond two outputs uh
what would we need to do
okay so uh what we'll do is
uh we'll first fix a linear ordering of
the outputs and it will become clear
very soon why
we are talking about linear ordering so
you can choose any linear ordering but
let us take a linear ordering let us say
it is
y 1 through y m and
what i'm going to do then is i'm going
to say that well okay i'm just going to
extend this
idea of coming up with a new
specification by quantifying out some of
the output variables
i'm just going to you know repeat this
for all of these variables in a
particular order
so for example the first time i will
quantify out all variables from 1 to n
minus 1
so these are the variables shown boxed
over here
and once i do that i'll get a
specification just in terms of x
and y m and that's a single output
specification i know how to get a
scoring function out of it
okay then the next time around once i
get that's column function for fm
i'm going to substitute that here so i
have shown by these
you know double squares over here the
substitution that's happening
and then i'm going to quantify out all
the variables from y 1 to y m
minus 2 in this new specification and
if i do that you will see that these
variables will be gone
y m is already expressed in terms of x
so now again you're going to get a
specification
only in terms of x and a single output y
minus 1
and we know how to solve the problem i'm
going to synthesize y uh
fm minus 1x from this adapted
specification and i could continue doing
this
until i finally reach the first variable
y1
at which point i have already obtained
column functions for all the other
variables
so i'm going to just substitute all of
them there is no further quantification
needed
and once again this is one output
problem so i know how to solve it
okay so this could be a way
of sort of you know dealing with
arbitrarily many outputs
and the ordering here is clearly you can
see that we have basically
generated this column functions uh as
per this order you can take any order
and we can do this but now the big
question is
that uh it appears from this strategy
that this quantifying out a bunch of
these output variables and composing
these column functions that i have
obtained from
uh some of the steps that have already
been taken
these two things appear to be very
central in this scheme
and the question is can i do this
efficiently okay so if i'm given the
specification
phi involving multiple outputs
i can indeed follow this strategy over
here to synthesize all these column
functions but i can do it only if
i can sort of do this quantifying a
bunch of variables
and substituting scrolling functions for
the other variables
if this operation if i can do
efficiently then
then we are in business and
this turns out to be the central
question that we need to answer
that is there a normal form is there a
representation of the input
specification
that will allow us to do this
efficiently
okay so what i am going to do now
is as promised i will talk about robd's
and in
in fact it turns out that robdddds
with some kind of variable ordering uh
enjoy this uh nice property that you can
do this thing
efficiently and i'm just going to
illustrate that how it works
so uh you know there's of course
uh there's a whole bunch of uh you know
researchers who have tried to
use this technique and developed for
several optimizations on top of that
so here what we're trying to do is we're
taking the specifications in robd and
this we want to generate this column
functions also as robd's
not just arbitrary boolean circuits uh
all of these work also generate the
scoring functions inside of bdds
and uh let me just show what an robd is
i'm sure most of you here are familiar
with it
but you know just for the sake of
completeness so
it is a directed acyclic graph in which
the nodes are labeled by
variables boolean variables and each
node
has exactly two children one is
uh you know connected through a dotted
edge and the other is connected to a
solid edge
so the dotted edge represents the low
child or the zero child the dotted edge
that's the solid edge represents the
high child or the one child
and uh you know this you can think of it
as a big decision tree folded into a dag
so here we are saying that if x1 is
false and x2 is true and y2 is false and
y1 is true
then the function evaluates to 1 but if
x1 is false and x2 is false and y2 is
false
then regardless of the value of y 1 the
function evaluates to 0
and similarly for the other parts and
you know there is a very rich literature
you know very very uh you know
beautiful elegant work which uh talk
about how to represent
boolean functions using our abilities
and the the nice properties that you
have
when you uh represent boolean functions
as robd's
different kinds of compositional
properties you have
so the key point for our purpose is that
for our discussion is that suppose i
represented the specification as an robb
ddd like this
then can i do synthesis from this
efficiently
in particular can i do that you know
quantification and composition
efficiently and it turns out that
it can be done efficiently if
the variables oh i must also say that in
an robdddd it's reduced
ordered binary decision diagrams uh
there is one key property that
if you take any path from the root down
to a leaf
there are only two leaves zero and one
if you take any path from the root down
to a leaf the
order in which you encountered the
variables are going to be the same so
for example
here if i take this path the order in
which i encounter is x1 before x2 before
y2
if i take this path i once again get x 1
before x 2 before y
2 and here also y 2 comes before y 1
so any path that you take the ordering
the order in which you encounter the
variables are going to be the same
and you know it is
known that uh depending on which
ordering
you use to construct your bdd uh
you to represent the same boolean
function you may get
a very large ability or a small and
compact bdd and therefore finding the
right variable order to represent your
boolean function or specifications
abilities of course an
important area of study and uh
what uh you know researchers have shown
is that if you order the variables
remember
the function that we want to represent
is a specification which has some inputs
and some outputs
and if you order the variables while
constructing the vdds such that the
inputs come first
so for example here you can see the blue
x1 x2 come
before the red y1 y2 in all paths
so this is called the input first
ordering of variables so if you
construct
your robdd reduced ordered binary
decision diagram
using input first ordering of variables
the inputs could be ordered within
themselves
in whatever way every permutation of the
inputs is fine every permutation of the
outputs is fine
but all the inputs must show up before
any of the outputs in any path
from the root to a leaf and if you do
this
then you can do the easy quantification
of y i's and the composition of f j x's
that we talked about in the earlier
slide and let me just illustrate this i
mean the basic intuition behind this is
actually quite straightforward
you know if your input variables are
coming first
then after you have traversed the input
variable so let us say i am saying
x1 is false and x2 is false and i am at
this node
right now if from this node there is a
path to the one leaf
it means that there is indeed a way to
assign values to y1 and y2 such that
you'll reach such that the specification
you'll reach
this one leaf which means the
specification will evaluate to true
similarly let us say if i come x1 is
true and x2 is false
and i reach this node and if once again
from this node there is a path to the
one node
it means that there is indeed a way to
assign a value to y2 and y1
such that you'll reach the one node in
fact there could be multiple ways of
reaching the one node there could be
multiple valuations of
y1 and y2 that you can use and you can
clearly see here so for example suppose
x1 is true and x2 is false and now i
need to choose the values for y1 and y2
you can clearly see here that the values
of y1 and y2 are correlated
if y2 is false then y1 has to be true
if y2 is true then y1 has to be false
right if y2 is false and y1 is also
false
then you will not end up satisfying the
specification because you'll end up at
the zero leaf
so so really if you order the input
variables first
then after you have traversed the input
variables you could be
standing at each of these nodes the
nodes labeled y2 here
and you could just read off the values
for y1 and y2 over here
right so for example here i could say
that well i
should set y2 to true because if i do
set y2 to false i'll reach
0 and after i have set y2 to true
then uh you know from here i should set
y1 to true
because if i set y into false after that
i'll reach zero and so therefore
you know at this point after traversing
the
inputs uh you can actually find out
what's
what should be the value for y1 and y2
and similarly at all of these points
and this now allows you to construct an
robdd
uh for y1 and y2 because right at this
point you can figure out whether y2
should be true
and if i2 should be true then what
should y1b and so on
in terms of uh the notation that we had
used earlier you know at this point if i
say that okay
does there exist a y one such that
phi x y evaluates to true all i'm asking
is that
from here is there a path to go to 1
okay because the values for x are
already frozen
by the path i have taken from the root
to come here and now i'm asking does
there exist
a value for y 1 which will let this
specification be true
so it's really asking that well from
here does there exist a path to the one
leaf
and if i were to take the path to the
one leaf
what should be the value for y2 so
that's what i get here
right so there exists y1 phi xy is y2
here
so at this point if x 1 is 0 and x 2 is
0
only if you set y 2 to true there will
exist a value for y 1
which will cause the specification to
evaluate to true and once you have this
uh you know you can just set you know
this is like a one output specification
so you can set uh that output to one to
get this column function so you get y2
as true
and once you have y2s
you know that you have basically
followed this branch vdd so now you come
here and you say okay now i want to find
out what is this column function for y
1 and you know you just substitute
1 over here so you come here and then
you see that y 1 also has to evaluate to
true
and that's what you get okay so
uh this basic idea of input first
ordered
uh robd's and citizen input first
ordered robb ddds
and of course uh you know on top of this
basic idea a lot of very nice
optimizations have been done
by these various papers in particular
this paper by freedom tabara
recently did very nice optimizations to
come up with a synthesis
tool starting from input first ordered
robd's
which can even be given as in a factored
form
uh it doesn't have to be given as one
monolithic capabilities so very nice
work
uh however the uh point that i want to
mention here and maybe we'll take break
after that
is that uh for robd's we indeed
know that uh the same function
uh for some variable order can require
an exponentially large arrow bdd and for
another variable order
can require a much more small much
smaller robd
and in particular if you're talking
about uh
relational specifications this is a very
simple
relational specification saying that uh
you know i mean if you think about it
the scoring functions for these are
already given here in the specification
right but if you try to represent this
specification
as an input first robdd what you'll see
is that
you have to first represent all
combinations of the inputs
and so you'll have to basically have as
many leaves
or as many intermediate nodes after you
have read all the inputs
as there are combinations of inputs so
there will be two rays to n
nodes at this intermediate level and
only after that because you can't
merge any any two of these because for
every possible combination of inputs
there's a different combination of the
outputs that's going to satisfy the
specification
so you have to separate out all of them
and so at this intermediate level
you will have two rays to end nodes if
there are n inputs and outputs over here
um and so the size is omega two raised
to n with input first ordering
but on the other hand if you chose an
ordering where you first
you know had x one and then you had y
one right so you can say okay
x1 can be either 0 or 1 and after that
y1 can be either 0 or 1 and if
the value of x1 matches the value of y1
then you go on to check x2 and y2
otherwise you directly come to the zero
leaf
so you can actually get a linear sized
robdb if you were to
interleave the inputs and outputs but if
you insist that you must have
an input first ordering then you get an
exponential size arabicity
so this really shows while uh you know
this technique is very elegant
and it really works very nicely when you
get smaller bdds
with input first ordering but you can
really end up in bad corners over here
so uh i think i will uh
so so yeah is is is this a good
point to take a break or should i
continue no i think this might be a good
point i actually had i'm i'm
i have a naive question so i didn't get
was it important
in this example so i'm probably
revealing that i didn't get anything but
never mind uh in this example
that you're doing is it important that
you have this
order why that y2 is the first y
variable and then y 1 afterwards like it
would have crashed if you
if you had y 1 first and then y 2 no no
so so you could have had
you could have any ordering on the
output variables but then the
order in which you will be quantifying
the variables and doing the compositions
will be as per that order
yeah that's what i mean but can you like
could you say just a sentence or two
like explain why this is so or
oh okay so uh as you can see uh i guess
the
the basic idea is that you want to
separate the inputs from the outputs and
you want to
sort of read all the inputs and then
come to a point where the only decisions
you're taking are on the outputs
right and uh if
uh you know let's say you are at this at
this point
so uh uh let me understand your question
so you're saying that if i had a
different ordering of variables i could
also very easily find out
this column functions at these
intermediate points is that what you're
asking
i'm trying to understand why this is not
i'm still sort of struggling to wrap my
head around what's going on
so it's an attempt to understand like
you know if i i would understand better
if i understood why you couldn't do y
one first and then y two
oh we could do y one first and then y
two absolutely
it would be perfectly fine no but
without switching the order
i don't like i yeah oh oh
maybe i'm not practicing the question
well that's fine oh i see i see so you
want to keep the same order in the robd
but you want to first get y 1 and then
you want to get y 2.
yeah can i offer a suggestion that might
explain this
i think he's saying that when the inputs
come before the outputs these are the
x's that's obvious
now in synthesizing the outputs the
order
has to be such that the first output you
put becomes an input to the second one
and the second one becomes the
to the third one and so the output start
behaving like
inputs for the for the remaining outputs
so that's why the order will whatever
order you choose you're going to get
different column functions but whatever
order you use
uh will make the uh second and third and
fourth outputs
dependent on the uh the area outputs
thanks karen that's extremely helpful
okay yeah
i think you explained it much better
than i did
because because i know bdds that's why
that's that's all
yeah yeah exactly
so i should have already taken the value
of y2 and then proceeded
so uh
yeah jacob so should should we take a
break i can take some questions and then
take a break
yeah more questions by voice or or chat
or
you know and then let's take a couple of
questions if people have questions and
then we'll
we'll take a break okay sounds good yeah
that requires us to ask some questions
though
so you know the people attending the
talk will have to collaborate and ask
some questions otherwise we'll take a
break right away
let's see if we have any questions at
this point
i don't see anything in the chat i don't
see
anything in the q and a
um so i guess
that means we're having a break i think
yeah i i i hope it doesn't
mean that all i said was unintelligible
but uh yeah i i'm
happy to take questions at any point
yeah so i think it was
very clear actually just to let you know
thank you thank you thank you
so then let's reconvene at
13 minutes to the hour so we're having a
10 minute break now
and then 13 minutes to the hour we'll be
back and if you want to
asking questions in the chat while we're
having the break is perfectly fine
okay are you in 10 minutes yes perfect
okay thank you
here's a matching video
let's see are we back
maybe
uh hi hi jacob oh yeah let me just turn
on the source of noise from the
background
let me turn
so everybody has had a chance to stock
up on
coffee or whatever you need depending on
the
time of day
i don't see any questions in
um
uh okay jacob yeah i'm ready
good we don't see yours
yeah your slides
is it visible it looks fantastic
okay
let me know when i should get going
so yeah so i i realized i have one
question more
in this example that you did
that we have now when you're looking at
i look at y2 so
i guess x x one and x
two they're like given to me i guess
we read those as inputs and then we just
walk accordingly
and then i've reached y2
and y2 i is what i'm going to set
and for every so i need to set y2
so that there exists choices of y1 that
will take me to the one node
exactly exactly okay
exactly
so if i make a question about the
ordering of the ys are there some orders
for which it becomes infeasible
it becomes infeasible uh
like you know once you've chosen a
particular value for
y2 then there is no value for y1 that
will take you to the
one oh yeah i mean for example in this
case if you choose y2 to be zero
no no i mean ever ever i mean so it
makes it impossible and ordering on the
y's there are some orderings on the y's
that uh will will make it impossible
no for every ordering of device we will
be able
so you know an robd has this property
that
once you've once you're at a particular
node if there is no way that you can
satisfy the specification
then that node will directly on on the
corresponding branch will directly lead
to zero
right so if the node is leading to
anything other than zero you know that
there is a path to one
right and so because we are representing
the same
overall specification regardless of the
order in which we are
putting the output variables so uh
for every ordering of the output
variables uh this
method will you know what essentially uh
it's like saying that after i have taken
a particular
path through the inputs can i reorder
the bdd that's rooted at that point
can any order the table send the b and
rooted at that point
right and any ordering will always have
a path to one is what you're saying yes
exactly because we are representing just
the cofactor of the original
specification with respect to the
assignment on the inputs
and so the different orderings of the
whites just give you different
implementations of them right different
functions
yes you could get different functions
but uh they will
all be legitimate scoring functions okay
yeah they could be different functions
okay
thanks there should be also some way i
guess so after the first
elimination step so like the
the r obdd that computes
y 2 for us am i right that it will read
x 1 it will read
x2 and it will have a one
and then it will output like what value
we wanted for y2
no no so the robdd for y2
would be it would read x 1 read x 2 so
so the r b
d for y 2 will look like the following
so at this leaf
it will have 1 because when x 1 is 1 x 2
is true y 2 should be 1
at this leaf it can be either one or
zero i just pick arbitrarily okay ah i
see i see i say okay
and at this leaf it has to be zero so if
you if you
sort of cut this uh robd here and
substitute
one leaf and here it can go either to
one or zero so basically these
distinctions don't matter and
here you if you put a zero leaf uh the
resulting bdd would be
uh right so you could put a zero here
for example if you could put a one here
it doesn't matter and then when i want
to do y one i will sort of take the
r o b d d we had before and sort of
contract away the white
layer exactly exactly so suppose you
have chosen y two to be 1 here
so now to get the arrow b d for y 1 you
will
sort of you know take the one branch
from here and let us say you had chosen
the zero branch here and the zero branch
there
so now your r b d looks like x1 x2
coming to this
node and this guy coming here
and so essentially this is i'm sorry
essentially these edges are sort of
struck off
edges corresponding to the values of y2
that you did not choose or struck off
and then you repeat the same thing for
y1
okay great thank you so much
okay so i guess we should let you uh
continue
okay so uh jacob how much time do i have
uh well i have been delaying you right
so uh
i wonder how much are you asking
uh yeah so i think uh if i have
around 40 minutes i think that should be
fine
okay yes okay let's go for it
thank you uh all right so
so so this was about robd's and uh you
know if you can represent it using the
input first ordering
uh you're in business uh but can we go
beyond
input first order robd's uh i mean truly
our opinions have much more structure
than we need
and uh what if we're fine with scolum
functions as circuits
and not as robd's can we avoid the
exponential blow-ups
uh what if the best variable order for
the specification is not input first
we just saw an example like that can we
do efficient synthesis for such
specifications
and uh fortunately the answer to that is
a yes
and the next representation that we're
going to look at
is a decomposable negation normal form
which was introduced by
a nun in a seminal paper and there is a
weaker version of that that
we also found works for the purpose of
synthesis
but let me just uh talk about what
decomposable negation normal form is
just summarizing uh you know
this uh special form so here uh
we have you know phi of x y
represented as a circuit and this
circuit is a negation normal form
which means all the negations are at the
leaves
and if it is the case that
for every and gate in the circuit
you can't find
two paths coming from
two leaves that are labeled by the same
variable
either in the same polarity or with
opposite polarity so it could be
z and z over here coming here to meet in
this and gate this is not allowed and
similarly z negation said here
that is also not allowed so if your
circuit is such that
the variables that eventually feed into
one input of an and gate and this should
be true for every and gate so if your
circuit is such that for every and gate
the variables feeding into one of its
inputs are completely disjoined from the
variables feeding into the other input
then this circuit is said to be in
decomposible negation normal form of
course this generalizes to multi input
and gate it can be more than two input
and gates also
right so the variables not just the
literals
the variables that feed into one gate of
an and gate must be completely disjoint
with the variables feeding into another
input of the and gate and this should be
true for every and gate
in the circuit so if if your circuit is
uh has this property then it is said to
be in decomposible negation normal form
and dnf has a lot of
beautiful properties which are then
talked about
a week or so back uh and what we are
really uh
going to use here is uh this notion
called dnnf
except on x which is that we require
this property
uh that you know variables feeding into
one
input are disjoint from the variables
feeding to the other input uh
only with respect to the output
variables we do not care about the input
variables
so uh you know we we can show that
if the specification can be represented
by a dnf circuit
uh by a circuit which is dnf except on x
which means that
no variables in y uh feed
there is no single variable in y which
feeds both inputs of an and gate
then uh you know
the the representation of the
specification in this dna f except
on x allows you to synthesize
scrolling functions in polynomial time
and space
okay so let me repeat what i just said
so if your specification phi of x y
can be represented as a circuit which
satisfies this property which is d n and
f except on x
which means that for every and gate in
the circuit
the set of output variables feeding one
of the inputs of the and gate
is completely disjoint from the set of
output variables feeding another input
of the same and gate
and if this is true for every and gate
in the circuit then
starting from the specification
represented by such a circuit
we can do synthesis in polynomial time
and space
okay now this can be generalized
slightly uh
further where we say that well uh
you know dnf would not allow uh
two paths starting from let's say z and
z
over here to meet up at an and gate but
we say that
well uh it's sufficient if you just
disallow paths coming from a variable
and its negation
so in particular it is okay to have a
variable and the same variable
feeding an and gate as long as they're
not in negative polarities
uh but you're
not allowed to have a path going from a
variable and its negation
meeting up at an and gate so there's a
slight weakening of the requirement that
we have for a dnf and we call this weak
dnf
and once again if your specification can
be represented by a circuit which
satisfies this weak dna property
then synthesis is once again doable in
polynomial time
and here we're using that in this for
negations is only at like leaf
level is that right yes so these are
the negation normal form uh so that's
why you know
if you have two y's then it's not like
one of them will be flipped later on
during the path that
that's like how it works because
actually both of them are feeding in
wise all the way right
exactly exactly exactly
okay uh and you know given any boolean
circuit
it can be converted to nnf uh you know
with that most
uh a linear blow up in size so
converting a circuit to nf is not a big
deal if you had negations inside you
just push them down
converting and stores or stones
basically de morgan's law
so that results in a at most doubling
the size of this
circuit so so this is a very practical
phenomenal form in that sense
okay okay but of course you know
an nf circuit may not be in dnf or weak
dnf
and it's only when the circuit has one
of these properties that we can
say that synthesis can be done
efficiently
okay so what we want to do now is uh
yeah and and the other nice property
about dnnf and wdn nf circuits
is that the quantification of y i's and
the composition of fj's can be done in
arbitrary order
remember we had fixed an ordering among
the outputs and then we were doing the
quantification and
composition in that order but if you
have your uh
specification represented as a dnnf or
wbnf circuit
then for any ordering you choose among
the outputs you can go ahead and
do the quantification composition and
still you will get polynomial time
and space synthesis okay
now uh so you know the
the the real contribution of our work is
to ask that is there
weaker than the weak dnf representation
that guarantees volatile synthesis
and the answer is synthesis negation
normal form
which subsumes and is exponentially more
succinct than the other forms
and then we ask that can we synthesize
column functions
given a specification uh you know
sometimes it becomes difficult to
convert it directly to a sin nf so can
is it possible to
simplify it in a very principled way and
then convert it to our
uh synonym and so this is what we call
refinement with respect to synthesis and
i'm going to
talk about this as well and finally can
we algorithmically compile phi
to a refined synonym specification uh
phi tilde and uh
you know we've done this implementation
the practical results look promising
but of course we must remember that
there are uh complex
load bounds so this compilation does
take super polynomial time in the worst
case
in fact currently it takes into the
worst case exponential time
okay but there are a lot of other uh
circuits that can be compiled
uh
much faster than exponential
okay so uh you know the classical notion
of knowledge compilation
is that it's a family of approaches for
addressing the interactability
of a number of typically artificial
intelligence problems
and so propositional model is
translated or transformed in an offline
phase to support several interesting
queries which can be answered
efficiently so this is the typical
uh knowledge compilation pipeline that
you're given a formula
which may be as a circuit or as a cnf
formula and then you compile it
to a certain special form could be a
binary decision diagram dnnf what have
you but once you have this
then uh in polynomial time you can
answer several interesting questions
that you wanted to answer about the
original formula so this is
the typical view of uh knowledge
compilation
so our definition of knowledge
compilation for synthesis is pretty much
the same
except that we are addressing the
interactability of synthesis
as opposed to uh those other problems
like model counting model enumeration
and all of that
so uh we take the specification phi
as a cnf or as a circuit and of course
we must
know what are the inputs and what are
the outputs in the specification
we saw in the factorization example it
makes a big difference
uh if you flip the rules of inputs and
outputs
and then we want to get this new
specification called refines in nnf
the the reason we add this refined and
not just the synonyms
is because we find that by doing this
refinement we can actually get much
smaller representations while still
guaranteeing that
uh whatever scolling functions we
synthesize out of this refined
f are also scrolling functions of the
original specification
so in our uh knowledge compilation
pipeline
uh this phi hat may not be semantically
equivalent to phi
but it satisfies a refinement relation
with respect to phi
but what it does guarantee is that uh
because it's in synonymf we can now
synthesize column functions
from it and every scrolling function
synthesized from this refined synonym
is also a scrolling function of the
original specification
okay so uh the way we proceed is
by starting off with the same nnf lag
that we saw for dnnf and weak dnnf
and here is a particular example
this is an nnf tag where i have kind of
shown the leaves
separately but in reality these would
probably be merged together
to have a dag and uh
you know these are uh the leaves
that have negated outputs on them
and uh what we want to do
is we want to replace all leaves which
have negated outputs on them
with a fresh variable so in this
particular case negation i 1 i will
negation y 1 i'll replace it with y 1
bar and negation y 2 with y 2 bar where
y 1 bar and y 2 bar
are fresh variables they are not the
logical negations
of y 1 or y 2. and
because i have done this change in
variables here so at the root
the function that is being represented
is no longer the original specification
it's a new specification
phi hat which is of course related to
the original specification
and we call this new specification phi
hat the positive form of this
specification so it has
all the leaves which had inputs on them
unchanged and all leaves which had the
outputs in positive form
unchanged and all leaves which had
outputs in negative form
are replaced by these new bar variables
uh
and that's the new circuit we have and
uh because this is an nf circuit which
means all internal gates are just
and and or gates uh it's now easy to see
that this circuit is monotone
with respect to the outputs and the bar
of the outputs
okay there are no negations that you're
going to encounter
if you start from an output or a bar of
an output and go all the way up to the
root
the only negations remaining on the
leaves are for the inputs
okay so there are some simple properties
of this
phi hat circuit and here is one
so if i take phi hat
remember from phi i constructed phi hat
by re-labeling the leaves that had
negations of outputs as their labels
so if i take the circuit phi hat
and substitute for
every leaf which has either y 1 or y 1
bar
if i put the constant 0 there now
remember if this y 1 bar was a negation
y 1 and i couldn't have
done it because if i one was 0 negative
y 1 would have to be 1
but now because i have a new variable
here i can do it and that's exactly what
i want to do
so if i replace y 1 and y 1 bar both
with 0
then i get an under approximation of
their exists y 1 phi
and if i replace both of them with 1
then i get an over approximation if
there exists y 1 and phi
and this is not very hard to see okay of
course you know
when i say under approximation of y one
phi the other variables which is like
negation y two stays
as negation y two it is so essentially y
two bar is
converted back to negation y two it's
just the y 1 and y 1 bar
the variable that you're quantifying
that variable and its negation
they are i mean not the negation the
variable replacing the negation leaf
they're both set to zero okay now i
could do this
for two variables also like if i want to
quantify two variables
then once again all the variables i'm
quantifying i will
change the negation leaves the negations
of them
appearing in the leads to the bar
variables and then i'll set all of them
to zero to get an under approximation of
exists y 1 by 2
phi and i'll set all of them to 1 to get
an over approximation of y 1 by 2 phi
and this turns out to be a very simple
way a very easy way
to get an under approximation and over
approximation
of quantifying out a bunch of output
variables
from the specification recall that we
needed to quantify out a bunch of output
variables
uh when we were talking about how to
reduce synthesis for multiple outputs
to synthesis for a single output so
uh this is kind of what we have i mean
this is
you know formalizing what is given in
the diagrams that if i look at the
outputs
so let's say there is 1 to y m as the
outputs
so i will have y 1 bar 2 y m bars
corresponding bar variables here now if
i set the outputs
y 1 to y i as 0
and the corresponding barred variables
over here is zero
and the other variables i make them the
negation of the corresponding variables
over here
then this gives me the under
approximation of quantifying out these y
variables from phi and similarly if i do
this for one
basically replace these with one but the
other bar variables i set them back to
the negations of the original
y i variables then i get an over
approximation of this quantification
so this is not very hard to show this
just follows from the monotonicity
of the circuits with respect to y i's
and y i bars
but now this has a very interesting
consequence
and uh so this is this kind of efficient
option
yeah so we're doing this on a base nnf
right no properties
just these substitutions
will not require any additional
properties okay thank you
no no no additional properties just a
base nnf
we know which are the outputs and which
are the inputs and we are just
going and relabeling negation outputs on
the leaves
that's all no other property
all right thank you okay yeah
so uh okay so now uh
this sort of leads to you know kind of
the central idea that
gives us the synthesis negation normal
form so what
we do is we given a specification
we convert it into its positive form
which is basically replacing all
negative output leaves by
fresh variables we use a linear ordering
of the outputs
and then we define this
you know quantity which we call the ith
reduct of
phi phi hat which is obtained by
just setting y 1 to y i minus 1 to 1
and y 1 bar y i minus 1 bar to 1
retaining y i as is and y i bar
as is and setting all the other y i plus
1 to y m
bars to the negations so you know we are
basically saying that
this is the ith reduct so the ith
variable is special so we are going to
keep y i and y
bar unchanged whatever comes before y i
in the ordering we're going to set them
to one both
in the normal variable and the bar
variable form whatever comes after y i
we are going to set them to the normal
variable and the negation of them
okay so this is what we define as the
ith reduct of phi
phi hat and here is a simple example so
for example the first reduct
is just you know replacing uh i mean
there are no variables before the first
variable to set to one
so we just keep y 1 y 1 bar and the
other variables y 2 and
so on we just keep them as is and
they're barred variables we just put
negation
okay so phi 1 uh 5
1 is kind of just setting uh
all the variables other than y1 and y1
bar to their normal
to their usual forms which is y i and
negation y i
but phi 2 hat is interesting phi 2 hat
is obtained by
setting y 1 and y 1 bar both to 1
because now
if i is 2 then i have to set all
variables before and the
part of those variables before to 1
and whatever variables whatever output
variables come after that i'll set them
to their negations in the bar form
here there are no variables after y2 so
nothing to set
to the negation form in the bar but y2
and y2 bar stay as they are so here
there is only y2 bar
so you notice that phi hat uh this the
second reductive phi
hat is not exactly
the same thing as just uh
you know setting it's not exactly the
same as quantifying out
1 and keeping y 2 and y 2 hat right
because we are replacing y 1 and
negation y 1 with
y 1 y 1 bar and then setting both of
them to 1.
if i were to quantify out y 1 i would
have to set this
to 1 and 0 or to 0 and 1 but here i am
setting both of them to 1
and because we need this ability to set
both of them to 1 that is why we did
this renaming of variables
right so the second reduction of phi hat
is
obtained by setting both y1 and y1 bar
to 1
if there were variables after y2 we
would keep them
the normal forms in their usual forms
that is
the the usual variables will be as they
are in the bar variables
with the negation and the special uh
variable
with respect to which we are doing this
reduction stays in the
uh normal form in the bard form right so
here it is y2 bar
so i mean these are just examples of
what phi hat the first and second redux
of phi hat would look like
and we can now do this for uh you know
all
eyes and why do we want to do this so i
think this slide
is going to be the central slide which
explains why we want to do this
so we've already seen that if i were to
quantify out a particular variable
then i can over approximate that by
taking phi
hat and setting y 1 and y 1 bar to 1
and renaming all the other bar variables
by the negations of the corresponding
variables
so this is the same as taking the first
product and setting y 1 and y 1 bar to
1.
because in the first reduct you know
there are no variables before the first
variable so there is
uh nothing is set to constants and
because i'm setting y 1 and y 1 bar 2 1
here so i'll just set those to 1.
so we've already seen that
the result of quantifying out y1 from a
specification
can be obtained by setting y1 and y1 bar
to 1
in the first product now we want to ask
under what conditions
am i going to get the implication in the
other way
okay so specifically we want to know
that when does the implication in the
other way get violated
and then if we can avoid those
situations then
i can actually obtain the result of
quantifying of y1
from the specification by just taking
the first product and substituting y1
and y1 bar to 1.
so we want to find out when does the
implication not hold in the other
direction
right what does it mean that i want
phi hat one with y one set to one and y
one bar set to one to evaluate to true
but i want exists y one phi x y to
evaluate to false
but what is exist y one phi x y it is
exactly 5 with y 1 set
1 disjuncted with 5 with y 1 set to 0
and we know that phi with y 1 set to 1
would be the same as
phi hat with y 1 set to 1 and y 1 bar
set to 0
right if you set y 1 bar to the negation
of y 1
then it's pretty much that we have not
done any change so it is just setting 5
with y 1 to 1
and similarly 5 with y 1 to 0 is phi hat
1 with
y 1 set to 0 and y 1 bar set to 1. so
this is the interesting part that when i
choose to set values
to y1 and y1 bar which are just the
complements the negations of each other
then it is as if i am setting the
variables in the original specification
to specific constants
but then because i have renamed negation
y1 to y1 bar
i also have this ability to set both of
them to the same value
okay and i know that that already over
approximates the existentially
quantified
formula so
so when does this implication not work
in the other direction exactly when
phi hat 1 with y 1 and y 1 bar both set
to 1 is 1
but when you set these to 1 0 and 0 1
they're both 0
and by monotonicity of phi hat if both
of them are 0
then when i set both the both y 1 and y
1 bar to 0
then i must also have 0. remember this
is monotone with respect to y 1 and y 1
bar
so you know if i reduce one of the
inputs
the output cannot change back from zero
to one
okay but now if you look at it if i look
at the function
phi hat one as a function of y one and y
one bar
so when both of them are 1 i wanted to
evaluate to 1 and when any one of them
is 0 i wanted to evaluate to 0
so this is exactly saying that we want
phi hat 1
to behave like y 1 and y 1 bar so this
implication in the other direction
fails when phi 1 hat behaves like the
conjunction of y 1 and y 1 bar
okay so if we can stop phi hat 1 from
behaving like the conjunction of y 1 and
y 1 bar
then this implication will not fail in
this direction
and we will get an equivalence over here
right the result of existentially
quantifying out y1
would be the same as phi hat 1 with both
y1 and y1 bar set to true
so the inside that we have is that
the result of quantifying out y1 from
phi would be
logically equivalent to phi hat 1 with
both y 1 and y 1 bar set to
true for all x and y 2 to y m
if there are no values of
x and y two to y m for which this
behaves like y one and y one bar
okay so i cannot find any value for x
and y two two y m
so that this behaves like y one and y
one bar when i substitute those values
if i can ensure this then
these two will be logically equivalent
and i can now inductively
extend this argument by saying that uh
i can get the result of quantifying out
i variables by
taking the ith reduct and setting y one
and y one bar to one
right if i can make the ith reduct
not behave so the ith redux should not
behave like y
y y and y i bar for any values of x
another remaining variables
so all that this is saying is that if
you can
reorganize your circuit or restructure
your circuit
such that you have this property that
phi hat 1
is never going to behave like y 1 and y
1 bar phi hat i is never going to behave
like y i
and y i bar and here you can see where
the definition of the weak dna f comes
in
if there is no path to an and gate which
can come from a
variable in the negation of the variable
then this this
uh i mean this phi hat one this
iterative reduction can never behave
like this and gate
right and so this is the crucial uh
idea that we want to say that an nf
specification
is in syn synthesis negative normal form
with respect to a linear order
if for every i in one to n i have this
property the ith reduct
does not behave like an and gate right
which means that
you know i mean if you look at this
formula this formula
can be i mean because it's just y i and
y i bar two variables here i can expand
it up
out into uh sort of four combinations
so i can say that phi hat i with
y i said to true and y bar set to true
either that should not evaluate to true
or
uh phi hat i with y is set to true and y
bar set to false
that should not evaluate to zero or you
know all the four combinations so this
basically becomes
uh a disjunction of four formulas uh
involving phi i hat
when when we want this uh equality not
hold with this equivalence not to hold
and we just want to check that that
formula is not satisfiable
for any values of the input variables
and the other remaining output variables
remember phi hat i already has the
variables
y 1 till y i minus 1 already
replaced by the constants one so
the only other variables are y i y i bar
and y i plus 1 to y m
so you know informally we are saying
that
can phi hat i be made to behave like
this
for any i and if the answer is yes then
it is not incident in it
otherwise it isn't cinnamon and f and
once we have
phi incinent and f then this column
function for y i
can just be obtained by we have already
seen this that we can existentially
quantify out the
prior variables and set the variable to
one
so this can be obtained by as just
taking the ith reduct
and setting y and y i bar one and zero
the ith reduct effectively quantifies
our
previous variables and then you just set
y and y bar to zero
uh y y at one and y bar to zero to to
mimic
setting of y i two one okay
so uh you know so this looks like that
if we can have this complicated
condition on the representation
uh then uh you know we can ensure
that synthesis can be run in polynomial
time and space
now this this condition looks
complicated because
we are essentially talking about not a
syntactic or a structural property but a
semantic property
right we are saying that give me a
circuit and then give me an ordering of
the outputs
and then i want to check if i set y
1 to y i minus 1 to true and y 1 bar
till y minus 1 bar to true
then can i make it behave like y i and y
i bar
okay so this is just a sad check and we
can do this by just
uh doing the sad check for a given order
so the restriction
is not purely structural it's not purely
syntactic
it is a semantic restriction and uh this
is actually reminiscent of uh
another very popular uh normal form that
is there in the literature
uh due to our nun and his students
which is called deterministic uh
decomposible negation normal form
where you have decomposable negation
normal form at
every and node that condition for every
and node and for every
r node you require that uh
the two sub formulas feeding into that
or node should be inconsistent should be
mutually inconsistent
so this is a semantic form which is
already there in existing normal forms
in the literature
and synonyms is also in that same spirit
it's just that
this condition is slightly harder to
state but
algorithmically it is not very hard to
implement this check
because we just take an ordering and we
just keep checking
whether uh you know this this
equivalence holds
and uh this is just a sad check
okay so uh
you know now let me just give a few
examples so here is
uh here is a formula five uh written as
an nf
tree uh and if you notice that this
formula is not in decomposible negation
normal form because you have
y 2 and negation y 2 going and meeting
up at an and gate
it is neither in weak decomposible
negation normal form because
you have y 2 and negation y 2 meeting at
the and gate
however uh we're going to show that this
is in syn nfs and this is negative
normal form
for this output sequence y1 before y2
so why is it incident nf with respect to
this output sequence
so we first ask that well can
i make this circuit behave like y1 and
y1 bar
for any values of the other variables
now notice that there is no negation y1
here so there is no y1 bar
so obviously this circuit cannot be made
to behave like y 1 and y 1 bar
okay it's all good then we say that okay
now let's look at y 2 but when looking
at y 2 i'm going to set
y 1 and y 1 bar both true there is no y
1 bar here so i just set y 1 to true
and then i am going to ask in the
resulting circuit
can i make it behave like y 2 and y 2
bar
now because i had set y 1 to true over
here
therefore this y2 no longer has of
reaching this and gate it's effectively
masked
and therefore this circuit can no longer
be made to behave like y2 and y2 bar
and therefore this satisfies the
synonymous requirement for y2 as well
so for this sequence y1 uh before y2
this representation is indeed in syn nf
now what happens if i flip this
if i say that would it be instead and f
with respect to y2 and y1
so in order to do that i have to ask
well can i make this circuit behave like
y 2 and y 2 bar
i have replaced the negation y to leave
with y
for some valuation of the other
variables now
here if i indeed set y 1 is 0 and x 1
is 0 then you know
i can and i believe x 2 to
1 so then
i can indeed make this like y y2
and y2 bar at the root and this means
that
this circuit is no longer in synonym f
with respect to this sequence
okay so the same circuit can be in
cinent with respect to one sequence of
outputs
and not with respect to synonym with
respect to another sequence of outputs
so of course you know checking whether
it is with respect
it is incident with respect to some
sequence of outputs is a hard problem
turns out that's in uh sigma 2p but
given an output sequence we can easily
check it by just doing these
sag checks okay now uh what is the
relation between bdds and cnnf so here
is another vdd i'm not sure if the
dotted edges are very much visible here
so uh you know i can convert each node
in a bdd represent
remember this uh was representing that
if y1 is zero go down this path if i one
is one go down this path
so i can replace this node uh by a
circuit where i have an or gate here
and on the left i have negation y1
conjuncted with
whatever is the circuit corresponding to
the bdd uh hanging here
at the left as the left child and on the
right side i have y1
with whatever is the uh you know circuit
corresponding to the bdd hanging here as
the right side
so i can recursively do this
transformation for every node and as you
can see
this just gives a linear blow up and
this allows me to convert any bdd
reduced ordered bdd into a circuit like
this and in this circuit if you notice
that every variable every output
variable and its negation
in fact every variable and its negation
will never meet up at an and gate
because the first time the meetup is at
an orchid
okay there is no way that they will meet
up at an and gate coming from two
distinct paths
so this already satisfies the synonym
property
uh and of course this is true even for
dnnf i mean this transformation
also converts robd to a decomposible
negative normal form
uh what about decomposible negation
normal form and weak decomposable
negation normal form
if you remember the property that you
can't have the same variable
coming and uh meeting at an and gate
through to its
two of its inputs this automatically
precludes
uh having something like y i and y i bar
because at an and gate you can't have
uh the same variable coming from two
different inputs
and similarly for weak d and f because
we uh
specifically exclude things like y i and
negation y i
so when you replace this negation y i by
y i bar you cannot have an and gate
which satisfies uh which sort of
implements y i and
y i bar so that's also ruled out
uh so a specification in dna for w dna
is already in synonym and this is for
any output ordering
uh and here are some interesting
observations about cinnamon and f that
every propositional formula is of course
representable
for every ordering of outputs for
example
disjunctive normal form is always in
synonym for any output order
a formula may have multiple synonyms
representations we have already seen
these
our abilities dn and f's uh
indeed a given representation may be
incident enough for one order of outputs
and not incident for another order of
outputs
uh and given an output order uh and an
nf specification
to check if that is in synonyms requires
these
uh sat calls really unset calls we want
to show that
uh the iterated deduct is not equal to
the conjunction of y
and y bar so it's it's going to be
complete
uh but if you want to given a circuit an
nf circuit if you want to check if it is
in cinep with respect to
some unspecified order then that turns
out to be in sigma 2p
and indeed you know
we have been able to show some
succinctness results as well
which means that uh there do exist
polynomial sized synonyms
representations
that only admit exponential size you
know ropd or
functional decision diagram
representations for any ordering of the
input variables
uh this the same is true even for x1
for dnf so there exist polynomial size
synonymous representations that admit
only exponential
size dnf representations uh there are
we we do not yet have a result about
exponential sized
uh deterministic dnf
but we do have this conditional result
that
it will lead to super polynomial size
deterministic dnf unless
uh p is equal to v and p so these are
two complexity classes which are not
known
whether they are equal or not but at the
same time uh synonymous is not
necessarily the most succinct way of
representing
uh a specification we do know that there
are polysized nf representations
that only admit super polynomial size uh
synonymous representations
unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses of course and so
here is some kind of an ordering so nnf
is exponentially more succinct than
synonymous which is exponentially more
succinct than
uh dnf uh i believe this is also
exponentially more succinct than
and f uh not exactly sure over here i
don't recall
uh others of course authority yes it is
yeah thank you uh and of course uh our
deterministic dnfs are exponentially
more succinct than
uh our abilities so uh
so that's that's like locating where
cinnamon is
in this uh entire you know knowledge
compilation map
as adnan had proposed
and uh what about uh how easy is it to
sort of take conjunction disjunction
with synonyms
formulas so if i give you two formulas
and synonyms
and both questions curious
yeah sure just like the previous slide
getting these uh containments
unconditionally do you think
like because you need like without any
assumptions about the polynomial
hierarchy or do you think this will be
hard
and stuff correct so so there are two
containments which are conditional
uh which is this nnf to synonymf
currently it is
conditional uh but i believe this uh
you know we have been thinking about to
make this unconditional but currently
this
is conditional this exponential gap uh
this is not conditional scenario dnf is
not conditional
a dnf to ddnf is also not conditional uh
i mean we we know that cinnamon and f2
uh
ddn f uh is super polynomial unless v is
equal to np
so you know i mean it is the case that
the the circuits that
show this gap may not be the circuits
that show
a doubly exponential gap over here right
so each each of these gaps are shown by
a specific class of circuits
and uh they are not necessarily always
compatible
uh and of course this this is also
unconditional so i guess
uh the in in the containment relation
shown here
this one is conditional uh and cinnamon
enough to ddnf
we have only uh super polynomial size
which is conditional
uh but if you look at them pairwise then
it's only this one which is conditioned
right now okay thanks
so i had a question about when you are
constructing cnn
then earlier you mentioned that it
should not behave like
the and gate but then you said that it
can be just checked with the set call
because the formula is
yeah so we want to check with the sat
call that it doesn't behave like an and
gate
so it's a coin b call
right okay uh
yeah so i mean just to i guess this this
picture showed it
here that we want to check uh
whether y2 and y2 bar uh
this is is there any assignment of
values to the other variables
after you have set y one and y one bar
to one which will make the output behave
like y two and y two bar
and if that satisfiability call says yes
there is an assignment then this is not
incident
if it says no then it is incident i mean
you have to repeat this for all the
variables in order
so it is incident okay
but then for most of the cases you
covered you actually won't need this set
call because you have like a structural
argument why it will
pan out yes yes so so the structural
argument
is weaker than what uh you know as
i showed that this this circuit was not
in dna for w
but it turns out to be in cinent so
there are circuits which are in synonym
f
which may not satisfy the structural
properties but of course the structural
properties are easier to check
and they're far easier to check right
okay
okay so uh
yeah let me quickly try to wrap up uh
uh yeah so what about the operations
so it turns out that uh computing the
conjunction of two formulas given in nf
both with respect to the same ordering
uh you know unless p is equal to np we
can show that
there cannot exist such a polytime
algorithm however computing the
disjunction
can be done uh in constant time you just
put an or gate
and connect them up that that does it uh
you want to existentially quantifying
how
quantify out the entire set of output
variables with respect to which
you have shown that this these are in
cinema f that takes linear time we have
seen we just need to set
the corresponding leaves and the bar of
the leaves
to one however if we want to quantify
out some arbitrary subset of y
this is not possible in linear time in
general uh
although uh you know dnnf uh and wb and
f will allow you to do this but not uh
synonymous in its most general form
okay so how does uh synonyms
help in scoring function synthesis
just give me a second
so i'll use the opportunity to highlight
what is already there in the chat that
for people who
wish to gather after the talk there's
gather town and i put the link in the
chat um
thank you antonina for reminding me that
there's a special
workshop space
and you can all go there and meet each
other and it's like you know almost like
in real life there are minor minor
differences but you won't notice
brutally
and and sometimes even the speakers make
it there although i think it's getting
close to midnight in mumbai so i don't
know if it's fair to expect that and you
know
people are still asking questions in
singapore closer to 2 a.m so that's
really you know being passionate
yes anyway so yes our speaker is back
yeah
uh yeah so this is just showing that
uh you know if you have your
specification
nnf then basically you start quantifying
out the variables and
setting the remaining single output to
one and zero and you get a scolum
function then you substitute this
column function quantify out the
remaining variables and so on
uh so if you start with your
specification in cinema
you can actually get all these column
functions you can get a circuit with all
these column functions
uh which which is m
times the size of the original circuit
and with order n squared additional
wires and so this is what
shows that uh and and this composition
scheme
and this setting of things to constants
uh
you know this basically achieves the
quantification
and this composition is of course
composition so this
this is what allows us to get a
polynomial time and a polynomial sized
uh solution to the boolean functional
synthesis problem
okay so as i promised i'll just take
maybe two more minutes to
uh talk about uh this notion of
refinement
and uh so uh suppose i have a
specification phi of
x y and uh let us say that
this blue box represents values of x
and this blue oval within it uh
represents all those values of x
for which there exists some y such that
phi of x y
uh can be satisfied uh
and this red box here are all this
column functions so this is the space of
all scrolling functions
and uh you know the things within this
blue oval here are the scolum functions
that suffice
for this particular formula phi okay so
here is the space of all valuations of x
and for these valuations i have a y says
that v of x y is true
uh and this is the space of all
scrolling functions and this is
the subset of scolum functions which i
can use
for y in this specification so we say
that
a specification of phi tilde on the same
input and output variables
is a refinement of phi if it satisfies
the following two properties
the set of x's on which uh
you know there exist y's such that phi
tilde is true
is at least as large as the set of x's
uh for which there exists y says that
phi is true
but the set of scolum functions which
suffice for phi tilde
is a subset of the set of scoring
functions
that suffice for phi right so you have
more x's where the specification can be
realized
but you have fewer scrolling functions
which can realize that specification
and uh if uh
if this is not a superset but an exact
it coincides exactly with uh you know
the value of x for which
there existed y so that p of x y is true
we call that a strongly refined spec
and then uh you know we have this lemma
which says that
if phi tilde is a refinement with
respect to phi
then every scrolling function vector for
y and
phi tilde also serves as a column
function vector for y and phi
and here is a simple example uh you know
on the
i mean here in the second line i have a
much
bigger more complicated specification in
terms of
x1 x2 y1 and y2 and it turns out that y2
and y1
is a refinement uh satisfies exactly
those two properties that
we said uh relative to this uh which
means that every scrolling function that
i can synthesize from y to n y one and
this is very easy to synthesize
just set both of them to true will also
serve as this column function for the
original specification
so the notion of refinement with respect
to synthesis allows us to simplify
specifications
without losing the ability of finding a
solution so it is something like the
equi-satisfiable
reduction uh but of course here
as i said the the number of possible
scolam functions reduces
which means that the the total space of
uh
solutions that i could have here is
could be less than the space of
solutions that i have here but sometimes
that actually helps in synthesis
if you have fewer solutions you need to
search over
okay and then there are some nice
properties of this refinement
both of them are reflexive and
transitive relations and then
uh you know so i will skip over these in
the interests of time
but essentially there are you know
several properties compositional kind of
properties that you have
uh that for example i think this
property is very interesting
so if f1 tilde is a strong refinement of
f1 and f2 tilde is a strong refinement
of f2
then f1 tilde disjunction f2 tilde is a
strong refinement of
f2 tilde and if you want
for the conjunction then f until the uh
conjunction f2 tilde uh is a strong
refinement of
f1 uh conjunction f2 uh if
there are some side conditions that have
to hold right some
output supports of f1 and f2 and
similarly of f until then
they have to be disjoint okay so this
actually allows us to comp
to look at a specification remember our
specification is a circuit
so we look at sub circuits convert them
to
uh refined specifications and then we
combine these defined specifications
to get the overall specification as a
refinement of the original overall
specification
and this has all been put together in a
tool called
c2cin which takes input and cnf and it
generates a refined
synonym specification which can after
that of course be used for synthesis
uh and this kind of uses
the same techniques as are used for
generating
uh deterministic decomposible negation
normal form
so uh you know we look at the
specification
choose a suitable ordering among output
variables branch on the output variables
and then for each sub problem we try to
come up with a
refined specification that is in synonym
f rather than a semantically equivalent
specification incident
and the details of this algorithm are
there in our paper
so we did some experimental comparison
uh with the qbf eval the
the two qb of formulas in the qb val
benchmark and the factorization
benchmarks
total of 408 uh and uh
you know this this synthesis thing
actually has multiple stages the first
state checks
whether the given formula uh you know
with some
very minimal manipulations is already in
synonyms so we do that
check uh whether it's behaving like an
and gate and it turns out
that a large number of them are already
in cinema with some very minimal
manipulations and then uh you know the
rest of them we have to
again go and uh transform them to
to get them in cinema uh if you look at
bdd compilation then of course uh you
know if you compile them into bdd then
of course they're already in cinema
so we can basically sort of and this vdd
can be compiled with respect to any
variable order it doesn't have to be
output variable it doesn't have to be
input first because vdds are just a
sub sub class of uh synonyms
and so here is uh kind of the final
slide where
i just want to point out these uh
scatter plots which show that
we compared this with uh you know two
other uh techniques
this is uh kind of the guess repair
check guest check repair paradigm and
this is the incremental determinization
which uses uh you know the things
cdcl heuristics to do boolean function
synthesis and i guess the the picture
that comes out from these plots is that
these are kind of incomparable
techniques and so perhaps they're best
used in a portfolio mode
you know for some benchmark something
works better some others something work
don't work better but i must also say
that the implementation of c2sim that we
have
is a highly non-optimized implementation
whereas cadet is a significantly
optimized implementation so there is for
the work that we're trying to do to
optimize the implementation
so in conclusion uh you know we
talked about a new normal form for
polynomial time synthesis
uh we talked about refinement and cnf to
refine synonymous is much more efficient
than cm
and experimental results show promise
and
uh you know i mean in recent ongoing
work we have been able to
show that even the synonymous
requirement can be further weakened
to achieve polytime synthesis but uh you
know that's still part of ongoing work
so i must thank all of you for staying
back so late
uh uh and uh
you know if there are any questions here
or in gather town i'll i'll come over
together downtown
i'd be very happy to answer them
thanks a lot surprise for a fantastic
talk um
so we have questions
just a question is is that easy on
nnf uh so
if you want uh yes so if if you
say that all your variables are output
variables
so i give you a formula right so
so i take a formula phi of x and i want
to
check whether phi of x is satisfiable or
not so i treat
all of the x's as output variables and
they construct a synonym form
with respect to all of x's then because
we can do quantification
uh you know very easily just by setting
the leaves
to 1 and the you know y i and y i bar in
this case x i n x i bar to 1
so i can actually quantify out all of
the variables
and so if if if i'm able to so if you
give me a formula if i convert the
formula to sin and f with respect to
all of its variables the entire support
um
then yes right so you you need that's
the point so
not for an arbitrary split of x and y
no no the the all the variables have to
be treated as y
okay thank you
so this is interesting because your
the problems you care about there is a
split of x and y
and it turns out that you have a form
that
would not be easy for sat but
would allow you to do synthesis which is
interesting so
pardon me uh oh yeah yeah so it's a form
that doesn't allow you easy sat
if you don't convert all the variables
to i mean
but but still allow you to do easy
synthesis which is important absolutely
and i think uh you know this kind of
dilemma is kind of best explained by
that i can take the same specification
and reverse the roles of inputs and
outputs
and i can certainly turn an easy
synthesis problem into a very hard
synthesis problem factorization being an
example so
what is an input and what is an output
makes a lot of difference
right and i think it probably has to do
with the fact that you do not require
the synthesized function to have any
particular form you don't require it to
be tractable
you just want it you just want the
function and
okay thank you yeah that is true that is
true
if you if you wanted the synthesized uh
scrolling functions to
also be in syn nnf with respect to
x for whatever reason or you know to be
in dnf
or something then it would be much
harder
right so so we are we are looking at uh
yeah i mean that would be an interesting
line to uh sort of explore
but currently we're looking at
applications where once you get the
circuit which synthesizes the scolling
functions
you're happy
good so do we have any other questions
before
those of us who can move over to gather
town
so i don't see so we were of course had
lots of questions during the talk
already
so then i think on behalf of the
all of the audience let me thank you so
pratik for again for a wonderful talk
um and uh
yeah thank you so much and uh we'll meet
again
in a week or on gather town
in a few minutes thank you so much okay
so i'll be there and gather down if
somebody wants to discuss something
further
i'll be happy
okay so